por fin se puede recorrer de nuevo la
carretera serpenteante de los
libertadores se reabrió esta semana el
principal paso entre chile-argentina
un alivio para los conductores
bloqueados en ambos lados de la frontera
llevamos 21 días esperando vine
descargue la mercancía volvía a cargar y
debido a la avalancha de nieve estuve
aquí dos semanas después de cargar
esperando para subir la carretera y
ahora parece que reabrieron ayer vamos a
esperar para subir la carretera
una carretera que estaba cerrada desde
que el 9 de julio las fuertes nevadas
registradas en la región de los andes
dejaron atrapados al menos a 250
vehículos pero no es la primera vez que
se cierra el paso de los libertadores
por culpa de las condiciones climáticas
se trata de una situación que complica
el trabajo de los que lo usan
regularmente la autoridad del organismo
no se preocupan tanto el argentino como
chileno de mejorar la infraestructura
nos hemos cansado mil veces de reclamar
según medios locales un promedio de 1000
camiones se trasladan cada día por la
cordillera